- When Oasis came along, we
didn't have the internet,
you know, if we'd have had the internet,
we'd have been bigger than the universe.
I don't live to work, I work to live,
and what's the point of being a rock star
if you can't just bum around for a year?
The gigs and the tours and
all that, you should be
having fun on those things
or what the fuck are we
even doing them for, I dunno?
- He's an English musician,
singer, songwriter,
and guitarist, he was
the vocalist, songwriter,
and lead guitarist for
the rock band Oasis,
many have praised his
songwriting, with George Martin
calling him the finest
songwriter of his generation,
he's Noel Gallagher, and
here's my take on his top 10
rules for success, and as
always guys, as you're watching
the videos, if you hear
something that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
as well, also as you are
writing something down,
it's much more likely to stick
in your head, too, enjoy.
(epic music)
- There can't be the
greatest band in the world
playing in a pub tonight
that nobody's heard of
with the internet, if you're
great, you going to make it,
you know, that's just a
fact, there can't be any,
well, we didn't make it
because we're working class
or summat, do you know what I mean?
Like, if you're writing the
best songs in the world,
you're going to make it in the end.
You know, when Oasis came
along, we didn't have
the internet, you know, if
we'd have had the internet,
we'd have been bigger than
the universe, you know what
I mean, we could have reached everybody.
- Yeah.
- You know, but we did it,
we were forced to do it
the hard way, you know,
these new bands have all
the advantage of, you know, these devices
that can get you to everybody in the world
at the click of a button, and, you know,
all they got to come up
with is, oh, right, yeah,
the difficult bit, is the f-ing songs.
(laughs) if you're a
songwriter or a composer,
you're kind of in it for
life, I enjoy the writing
although it can be very
frustrating when it's not happening
but I do enjoy that, I genuinely
don't know what I would do.
- Some people from some
quarters give you steak
for being, like, a formulaic songwriter,
but I'd say, Chasing Yesterday
is kind of progressive,
really, isn't it?
- Some of that, well.
- Relatively speaking.
- What does that mean,
anyway, what does it mean
and who are some people, the
Guardian, because the Guardian.
Everybody's got an opinion
anyways, do you know what I mean,
but I don't really
think about it too much,
if it sounds good to
me, I put it out there,
I'm not begging people to come and see me
or buy it or anything
like that, if my audience,
if such a thing exists,
gets it, that's great
and if they don't, that's great, too,
you know what I mean, I kind of like it.
- Creatively, where were
you at at the end of Oasis?
- Creatively, well, I would
always take a lot of time off
after big world tours anyway,
do you know what I mean?
You've got to, if I
was, 'cause each project
that we used to undertake would
be two years with the tour,
from the minute you enter
the studio to the end
of the last gig would be
two years, so you've got to,
if I was working for two
years, I'd have to balance
it out with time off because
I don't, I don't live to work,
I work to live, and what's
the point of being a rock star
if you can't just bum around for a year?
There's no point in working
every day of your life.
- Do you consider it work,
some people would look at
your life and think that that work isn't,
is something, it's your
passion, so it's ...
It's what you live for.
- On the one hand, it's my
hobby, do you know what I mean
and I don't have any other
hobbies but watching football,
but, you know, like I
say, I couldn't go from
spending two years on a project
and then six weeks later
saying, right, well, I'm going
to start something else now,
there's got to be, now
this is just me personally,
some people like to work all the time,
I have to go away and I
don't pick up the guitar
and something happens
and then I have to feel
that I really, really miss
it, like I might go and see
a show from another band
and think, I really want to
get back on stage, you know,
and then I'll think about
doing something, we're
all in the music game
for different reasons,
do you know what I mean?
And I am not a workaholic, I'm just not.
I pay for and release my own
records, and I produced it,
I don't have anybody
saying to me, well, I think
it's a bit long, you know,
or an A and R guy saying,
why does the guitar solo come
in after the first chorus,
and then there's a big,
do you know what I mean?
I allow myself now to follow my instincts
and sometimes they're wrong
and sometimes they're right,
you know.
Well, I believe in what
I do, in the same reason
that I believe in and I'm
comfortable with who I am
and what I wear and how I
look and how I'm perceived,
I take the writing and
the recording of my music
very seriously and the rest
of it, I don't take seriously
at all, I don't take myself seriously,
I don't take things like
these interviews seriously,
I would never do an interview
where I'm like, well,
you know, tell you how I wrote
that song or what it means,
nobody gives a shit, I
don't care, you know,
so yeah, I don't take a
great deal of it seriously,
if I'm being honest,
apart from the records,
they're serious because they last forever.
The gigs and the tours and
all that, you should be
having fun on doing those
things or what the fuck even
are we doing, I dunno.
Funny thing about gigs is ...
There's so many factors
that make a great gig,
like, I mean, I've come
offstage so many times thinking
that was awful, for
whatever reason, you know,
your sound man'll come
in, he was out front,
to say, that's the best
thing I've ever seen,
you go, really, or then you'll be offstage
and think that your band has played great
and the sound man'll come in
and say, oh, I lost the bass
for six songs, you're, like, really,
or the lighting man'll say,
well, yes, but the lights
didn't work, you know
what I mean, it's kind of,
I don't really, I don't really judge gigs,
while I'm doing it, I'm just
in the moment, I'm singing
the songs, when I come
offstage, I don't like talking
about it.
- So when you're writing
a song, I mean, how do you
put it to, what's the process?
- I just play the guitar,
I might be playing a set
of chords for three months
and I will just be fascinated
by the chords and nothing
will happen and then one day
if I perservere with it
enough, a melody will arrive
and then lyrics will evolve
and then to get a band to play it,
I come from a school of music,
well, we all did in Oasis,
where you just say, right,
it goes like this, you know,
I don't know, I know the
chord E, I know quite a few
chords, the major chords
now and the minor chords,
but when we get into
suspended and augmented things
and all that, I find that,
I just, I don't know what
they all are, but, yeah,
it was more the punk ethic,
it goes like this, just
play along and I'll copy it.
- You're an independent artist these days,
what do you enjoy most about
being I guess not releasing
music on the major labels?
- I enjoy the lack of money that I make.
(audience laughs)
I enjoy the lack of
record sales, I also enjoy
the lack, I enjoy the lack of recognition
and the lack of rewards that I receive.
'Cause quite frankly my
mantelpiece, it was chock a block
with the f-ing things, so ....
(audience laughs)
It's nice to take a
backseat, I enjoy not working
with people in record labels
who are in fact, as we all
know, (bleep), so ...
(audience laughs)
It's nice to get away from that mob.
- I've never felt the need
to be in the public eye
or the need, even when I
was in Oasis, I was always
the last person to get on
board to go back to the studio.
I never really, that never
really, I don't chase my,
I don't chase fame or success
or anything like that.
I mean, I was kind of,
I'd taken about a year out
and, you know, I'd written a lot of songs
and I'd demo'ed most of them,
and there just came a point
where I felt I should get in the studio
but not for any other reason
than to record these songs
and see what they sounded
like and I didn't really tell
anybody, I kept it quiet
for a year and a half, and
it was all very relaxed and
low key, it was just me,
an engineer, a drummer, and
a part time keyboard player
who came in and out, and
there was only three of us
in there and it was done
very kind of leisurely,
and then, you know, my
wife went and got pregnant,
so I had six months off
looking after my new son
and all that, so it was very,
it was quite a leisurely
pace, some might say majestic.
- [Woman] You could have
easily decided to, you know,
start to retire.
- Well yeah, yeah.
- [Woman] But you didn't,
but you're still enjoying making music.
- I've never lost the sense
of wonder of writing songs,
you know, in that sense
I still feel like I'm 25
when I was writing
Definitely Maybe and thinking
that's just f-ing great,
you know, I just mastered
the art of writing my songs and I loved it
and every time I finished
a song it was like, oh,
another song, I still get that feeling,
and as long as I don't lose
that, I'll always make music.
- Thank you guys so much for
watching, I made this video
because IGPK1987 asked me
to, so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see
what I can do, I'd also love
to see what did Noel say
that had the biggest
impact on you and why,
what would you take from this video
and immediately apply
to your life or to your
business somehow, please
leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the
discussion, I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Reverse Stereo,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that
fun YouTube tribute video,
I really, really appreciate your support.
(upbeat music)
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.